welcome everybody my name is Jakob
capella I am part of the Play business
development team based in Berlin and I'm
happy to have you here at this late hour
for the last session of the day we call
it the graveyard shift
please stay awake bear with us a little
bit longer we're the only three people
between you and Tabar so that's that
should that should give you some hope
there's light at the end of the tunnel
the topic of the panelists will be
already being communicated to you
bye-bye Tamsin driving conversions on
Android apps now what are conversions
conversions are in my opinion the
essence of what all of you guys here are
doing the best possible outcome the
result of a good job within the buckets
of quality apps engagement retention
churn if you get all of those things
right the conversion will come up
however a conversion is not necessarily
a purchase and a conversion can happen
all along the user the user fight the
user journey think about think about
your own user journey during a normal
day you wake up in the morning you turn
off the alarm clock you check the news
you check the weather you check your
messages your emails your snaps your
tweets your arrange dates you work out
you pay for lunch you hail a cab you do
some shopping you buy gems for your
favorite games all of those interactions
can be conversions to the respective
developers moments of opportunity so
there are loads and loads of different
types of conversions on Android apps and
in general you can categorize them and
distinguish by two types one is on
platform happening on the smartphone
within the app or the game and the
second one is off platform triggered by
something on the app or as on the
smartphone or in the app or the game but
happening in the real world so I had a
lot of conversations over last weeks
with developers what could be
interesting for them to listen to in
this panel and to discuss around
conversions
and the statement or the feedback
reconfirmed my viewpoint that
conversions is something that cannot be
fought about one dimensionally biases
having one KPI it's a multi-dimensional
issue and for that I tried to structure
it in four buckets and again I'm gonna
put the fingers number one is the basics
so anything that's around the definition
the prioritization the correlations the
interdependencies of KPIs the second
bucket is everything around
organizational issues so anything that
goes with processes workflows team
structure and so on and so forth the
third bucket is what you would have
expected this panel to be about after
all anything that's in product
optimization so UX UI behavioral design
hooking nudging anything the fourth
bucket is around out of product
optimization so anything that's
happening outside of the products in the
funnel influencing your conversion
luckily I have found two very
interesting partners that have an
amazing story to tell to all of those
four buckets whilst at the same time
being from completely different
industries completely different business
models and different stages in their
company lifecycle on the one hand I'm
having Nicholas Johnson who's one of the
cofounders of blink kissed
blink kissed is an education startup
based out of Berlin that takes the
content of nonfiction books distills it
into small little packs that can be
consumed while reading or listening to
and then creates knowledge for the user
Nicholas is responsible for product
strategy and ensures that the culture is
flourishing in his own words on the
other hand and welcoming on stage with
me Andrea Tino he is the director for
technology weapon apps for a sauce a
multinational shopping destination huge
business he and his teams are looking
after the products within web and apps
and trying to build an amazing shopping
experience for all of their users
globally so what further ado please
welcome with me on stage Nicholas and
Andrea
oh hello cool thanks for thanks for
joining us guys I'm actually going past
this one so we've had a lot of
conversations and by now we actually
know each other quite well so without
further adue directly into the into the
basics I know or before I started our
conversations I thought that the topic
of conversions could be a very easy one
at linked lists you're trying to sell
subscriptions and at ASIS you're trying
to sell fashion right now unfortunately
or fortunately you could say I've kind
of been well this this this breeze this
premature assumption wasn't correct and
it's a little bit more complicated than
that Andrea I am going to ask you first
what are the basics of how you look at
the conversion topic at a sauce hello
everyone and before I start I want to
say that my Google now was trying to
suggest how to say good evening in
German and actually I already forgot it
that's really really bad stuff but I
think what I can start with is a first
point at day time machine learning much
better than humans humans are learning
and giving you the right inputs so I'm
particularly happy to join the topic
about the conversion rate because it's
been one of my personal Crusades in the
last couple of years in my career for
those of you are not familiar with an
e-commerce business the conversion rate
is defined as simply as the number of
orders divided by the number of visits
and the one of the easiest way to win an
argument and explain to people like
Jacob how conversion rate is not the
holy grail of any commerce is just
making an example of if you're the
company a making five orders out of ten
visas or you're a company be making six
orders out of twenty visits you'll
probably say the conversion rate of the
company a is better well actually if you
have to if you really think about it for
like two or three seconds you will
probably want to imitate the company
beam it doesn't matter how many visits
you get it doesn't matter how many
orders together as long as get the most
of both of them
so that's why I think commercial rate
has to put be put in context this is why
addresses we look at commercial rate
obviously is one of the metric but then
we also care and actually we care most
about the engagement as well for our
Android apps we look at active installs
monthly active users the frequency or
how often they come back to our
properties and how much time they spend
when they are in Apple then you take all
these metrics and you do your product
optimization based on the customer
lifecycle rather than a single metric
like the conversion rate but do you
prioritize them at all there yes for
sure when you're in a company with 4,000
people you need to probably you need to
give a clear prioritization otherwise
you can have bombarding by every single
person with the top idea for your
product so we get fighty based on a
number of metric again there could be
revenue from a revenue point of view
from an engagement to fluent in view
from a brand awareness point of view and
also also have to do legal requirements
with the combination of metrics and once
a month we could do a parody session
session across the whole company okay
how does this so how does this look like
at the uplink is this user centric
approach yeah so I think it's so what
you said before in the beginning that of
course one of our business courses to
sell subscriptions that's that's true
that's very simple but the way to sell
the subscription is probably much more
complex than just looking at a
conversion rate as a KPI so we don't
think what conversion is just one KPI we
think of about conversion as a user
journey which starts often in the App
Store and ends at the point where the
person makes a decision ok blink this is
a product I want to spend money on
because it really brings me value in is
something I want to have like use on a
daily weekly basis so when we look in at
conversion or like the outcome of
conversion we think of this journey
there are a lot of small micro
conversions along the way and you can
optimize a lot of them with the goal of
creating the outcome that is selling a
subscription so the way we approach this
there are plenty of what we call proxy
KPIs
so we think that KPIs that happen very
early in the funnel for example or we
say if this happens users much more
likely to convert afterwards the
conversion is the outcome that we
measure the success based on but we will
we would not rather optimize for micro
conversions along the way which then
lead to subscription so for example one
thing we try blinkers is that instead of
just looking at screens of lows that
would directly to conversion we try to
map the whole user flow beginning at the
App Store to the onboarding to the first
user experience to the upsell flow and
really try to understand what is either
going through what I experiencing what
is holding him back from making a
purchase decision and then optimize this
step by step and these optimizations in
the end lead up to a higher conversion
rate may be very interesting to
understand how we work is that I think
for product people the App Store the App
Store page especially something you
don't spend much time thinking of
because it's often taken care by
marketing teams and we actually tried to
bring together the marketing team the
Prok development team even a Content
team to look at the whole funnel
together and then prioritize experiments
together that would then lead to a
higher conversion rate and also the
formal structure is then accordingly so
yes I would say there are two ways we
like first prog development is
structured in in full SEC teams around
our main business teams that are new
user activation and subscribe'
engagement so we want to convert people
and we want to keep them as a lifetime
customer once they converted but at the
same time the product evelopment teams
work very closely with the marketing
teams for example they have weekly
check-ins where they approach has would
look at data together and prioritize
experiments to run ok and how are those
two teams staffed and if I can ask the
product teams they are staffed as you
say full stack so they have mobile
engineers there for mobile engineers for
each team they have a product manager
they have a designer and they have a QA
person ok
ok interest and how is it now obviously
asus is a lot bigger than than than
blink is how is that how is the
organizational structure affected by the
way you look at conversions at asus so
the numbers are slightly bigger but the
concept I think is quite similar the
answer we divide our technology based on
our architecture so the Micra we have a
micro service architecture so we have a
number of what we call platform teams
looking after every single let's say
service in the e-commerce platform so
you can imagine the payment service the
product service the subscription
services etc and then we have in the
front end teams like the iOS team the
Android team and web team so that could
bring a little bit of more separation
from what Nicholas was describing but
actually what we do is we stitch all
together with our product buckets so we
look at the as I was saying at the
beginning we look at the customer
lifecycle and we split the our
activities and our products in three
phases the first phase is discovery then
there is fulfillment and then there is
retention
the discovery is all about how you bring
new customers or laps of customers to
other properties how you show them what
what's new in a platform what's new for
them and how do you can inspire them
through our content campaigns and
products then its fulfillment
fulfillment is once you've been very
very inspired and you really know what
you want what you're after then is
everything starts after so everything
about making your purchase the safest
possible giving you the most important
that relevant information like
suggesting you you recommended sides or
giving your the product information
assets videos etc about that product and
then all the checkout process making it
as fictionalist as possible and then
there is the last bucket the last bucket
is how you build the relationship after
the purchase so how you can bring back
the engagement how you can help them to
engage with you like checking where is
the parcel getting what it was new in
the SS Ward what else can be engaged
them from a loyalty scheme point of view
so all the activities that are meant to
bring their engagement back after the
conversion is already done okay and so
you told me you have nine hundred people
in the tech segment in aces how do you
make sure that all of those people
didn't stay sync with this structure I
wish I wish I know I see the bullet for
this answers the reality is we tend to
do we work it I don't say that we work
very very closely together across the
business this is the one of the beauty
of the company so we tend to have a
biweekly session with all the product
management with that data and analytics
guys we work on a monthly paralyzation
session to make sure that we are all
aligned to the top priorities of the
business
we tend to use every single tool
possible in terms of communication to
keep everyone engaged with this is
what's going on this is what it's gonna
be in beta for the internal employees
this is what it's gonna be in beta for
new customer successor so we plan to
spread as much communication as you can
okay cool
Niklas actually one more question to you
so I know that traditionally you've
originally you follow the very
traditional approach in terms of team
structure you only change to that
structure you described recently and
that this was a challenge at the
beginning you want to talk a little bit
about well first of all the reasons why
you change and then secondly the
challenges and how you overcame them
sure so I think there the main the main
reason why we did it can be summarized
in one word which is Pizza the long
answer to that question early so we kept
growing as a prog development team and
at some point year for 10 10 12
engineers 2 3 product managers 3 4
designers and the team just got too big
and there's this Pizza rule from Jeff
Bezos the founder of Amazon he says if a
team gets too big that you can't feed it
with like more than two pizzas you
should split the team and we were at
this point where I said okay either we
come like like we have to split the team
in a way and then we thought okay what's
the best way to split the team we said
okay let's organize the team around our
business goals or main themes which are
activation and retention so that was the
main idea that like every team has a
mission they can follow and really work
towards a shared purpose as a team and
not only have like doing features I
think it's very important especially for
developers today now that the features
they're building what they paint what
and the second reason was like we
believed that it could paralyze output
Sonya in the in the past would always
have to prioritize experiments either
for conversion or for retention and now
having two teams that can run
independently allows us to ship
experiments on both sides at the same
time challenges again of course it's
like huge there's much more
communication needed because suddenly
you have teams that run independently
but still work on the same code base
neither the covergirl shared release
process and I would say probably the
recesses there was the biggest challenge
coordinating different releases
different feature branches bring it
together so that you can in the end
release one version to these stores cool
and that actually leads us directly to
the next bucket for all of you who paid
attention
we just discussed bucket number one the
basics and two which is the
organizational pieces and we're gonna
move on now to three and four so next
part the second part of the panel is
about the experimentation the nitty
gritty stuff and the secret sauce of of
what you guys were finding out during
all of the testing that is happening and
that is happening at all times in your
businesses so in product optimization
testing obviously there are loads of
different ways to find success for each
of your own businesses which is why the
examples we picked between aces and
plinkus are only examples to inspire you
and to take home with you for potential
opportunity to test within within your
own businesses niklas we've been working
together a couple of months back with
your teams and our teams on a project
where we applied behavioral design
principles that were presented earlier
by my colleague Jenny to your business
and where you did some experimentation
around that do you want to talk about
this and I hand you the clicker sure so
I've read one experiment brought us from
like many for two reasons the first
reason is why it's very interesting
because it changes it shows a change and
how the way we approach experiments a
blink is so in the past we have been
focusing a lot of small experiments just
like changing one variable at a time and
see what the outcome is but realized as
a company we haven't really found like a
perfect flow for us we thought let's try
bigger experiments let's have just like
something that can really move the
needle and try more of those and we
don't really care if we if we change ten
variables in this experiment or we care
about is that the outcome for example
the conversion where it goes up and yet
because and yet you can like make a lot
of assumptions why something goes up but
what measures eventually is that
something goes up the second reason why
I bring it is because it is exactly what
Jacob mentioned there are some
psychological figures we analyzed and
why this experiment worked indium so
what you see here is or old onboarding
flow this is what you what happens right
after you sign up you get in you get a
24 hour trial right away you don't have
to opt in for anything there's no
strings attached you can use the product
or 24 hours for free and after that you
have to upgrade to keep using the
product um
this is great because there's no strings
attached it's very transparent for the
user what I can get out they can use the
product on their own like at their own
time at the same time 24 hours is quite
like it's not enough time to use the
product and people were still like a
little bit confused and we what we
mostly lost is this urgency so people
can use it they can come back text seven
days later but there's nothing where I
say okay now I have to subscribe or no I
have to collect we buy a subscription so
what we change this this is the new
onboarding flow and as you can see there
a lot of things that changed the first
thing is that the layout change the
pop-up changed the subscriptions between
how we from seller subscription so we we
promote them change but most importantly
what changed was that we change from
this 24-hour no-strings-attached free
trial to a 7-day purchase no trial so
I'm not sure if I have to write words
for that but what Google Play offers you
is that a user can start this free trial
for seven or thirty days but after the
seven days or 30 days this subscription
is automatically in turns in a
subscription if they don't cancel within
the seven days so very similar to what
you know from Netflix for example when
you subscribe for the first 30 days free
trial after 30 days if you didn't cut if
you didn't cancel you become subscriber
so we changed this more this model
completely different for each file model
longer trial period
it turns automatically we changed the UI
and we saw one at 50% increase in leads
have v10 conversion rate and in average
revenue per user the thing is we can't
really tell you why that is what we like
they're like love the things we change
but what we see it like really increased
the revenue so the takeaways from this
is the one side obviously it was like a
really large scale of purchases we
tested here yet for us work really well
instead of just doing very incremental
optimization if you change the flow it
can really change the mechanics of your
complete of your funnel completely if
you look at the distribution curve so in
the past you see a lot of the day of the
purchase has happened after the first
months actually
so no most of the purchase is more than
nearly 50% of the purchases happen in
the first month actually most of the
purchases happen on the first day in the
first session so most people start a
free trial and
stick around and become a subscriber so
the whole funnel changed completely
which of course is a new challenge for
marketing and for pro communication but
we know every new playing field what we
can optimize from so we dare to do a big
change I would have liked encourage
everyone to do big changes and just try
to be transparent build for us don't I
think one big learning was as well like
the old model although we Pacifica is
very fair you just didn't really get
that it's fair the new model is a little
bit less fair you can say but it's more
transparent because people are used to
this to this flow for example mmm very
cool really good insights Thanks thanks
for sharing Andrea now at Asus I assume
given the size of the company they're
always a be test going on and you picked
I think one or two special ones yeah I
really like to make my pointer to win my
arguments I picked a couple of tests
there are very very controversial so
please bear with me the last ten minutes
of the session so what I want to show
you is a couple of tests we've done in
the Android Apple and the first one is
about the having proposition banners in
the product page what we mean by the
proposition is mostly refer to the
delivery solution and we picked a couple
of example one is our premier delivering
so similar to another big company called
prime something and this is really
subscription in English you get Next Day
Delivery for free and the second one is
was just banners say actually for your
orders you're gonna get three delivering
returns as you can see done at numbers
somewhere on the screen the first banner
drove a crazy amount of visits to the
premier delivery subscription that tells
obviously people want to know more about
the subscription and actually probably
the awareness wasn't great up to the
point and the second actually the second
banner the Friedan even returns brought
to a less engagement in terms of going
tapping on the banner but in terms of
the overall results the second banner
was the one performing bringing a
commercial rate increase Minh it
increased so which one would you take I
think everyone will go for the second
one to get services the one is bringing
more money home but actually what we did
is we went completely for option C and
we decided to build a much more complex
solution having like a sec
segmentation are across our customers
and targeting each type of customers
with the different propositions if we
know that the customers already shopped
with us it is most likely to be
interested in the premier subscription
we serve that message if actually is a
brand-new customer that doesn't have a
history with us we serve the other
banner so that was the first trick now
the second trick is about pushing people
throughout the basket this is like if
you talk to every single designer they
will always try to sell you we need to
make the main action more prominent we
need to have this very very easy you
like even if you stumble with your phone
you need to tap at the back so that's
what we're done so we're done a couple
of variation and for most of our
products obviously you need to select
the size before going to add the product
to the bag so with an T variation one
was to have a sticky actually it doesn't
really I think we couple it with the
slides but basically it was a sticky
button to have the add back button on
one side and variant one and a sticky
button to select your size on the
variant two now the the outcome of both
variation they're all the higher
engagement with people having to back
because you're making the action just in
their face and then again if you look at
the KPI of this test in isolation if you
think my objective was to drive more
people to add to bag
thumbs up pick one this is success I
think number two is got 14% so we should
develop number two when you open your
eyes and you look at the whole picture
of what are you doing to the customer
behavior then were we work experiences
that there was no change in the orders
and actually for for an e-commerce
platform like ours in which we have a
huge variety of products and the our
catalog is super quick so every 12 weeks
we change completely all our products on
the website our stock availability is
one of those things that triggers you a
little bit of pressure in order is
something that's why when we add
something to the bag we reserve the
stock for you for 60 minutes so if you
do if you succeed with this experiment
you're bringing people pushing people to
add more stuff to the bag they're not
buying eventually more what's happening
is you're reducing the chance for other
people to bind so all of this to try to
say basically when you do a test you
need to be very clear and what's the KPI
on the test but you also need to have a
a clear view of what else is is
impacting the customer behavior all the
experience Wow okay that's a lot of
input very good so we're at the end of a
physical baguette three and four we did
three in four yeah we're at the end of
the of our of our time actually and I
think we should times up there is design
perfect so there was a lot of input and
good examples obviously on on how to
optimize in your product we didn't get
to do around the product but there is a
lot of information on that as well
that we're gonna release later on I
think what's interesting and I think
that's for me the main takeaway is look
at it holistically don't look at one KPI
and don't may don't isolate keep you
guys from each other but look at it
holistically and in a sustainable manner
don't maximize short term for one single
KPI that's gonna then decrease other
KPIs that you're not looking at so much
so that's my takeaway however I'm 100
percent sure it's not gonna be as clever
as your takeaways which is why which is
why I'm actually gonna let you close the
panel from all of the things that you
talked about today or even the things
that you didn't mention what would be
the one thing that you would give the
audience to think about now after when
they have a when they have a drink Nick
Nicholas I wondered first to say good
things happen met the happy hour here
but I think I like their to take away
would be be obsessed with the problem
not a product I think that's probably we
often get upset with the project self
but we should always take a step back
trying to understand what is the problem
we're solving and try to put ourselves
into our users shoes and see what they
experience and optimize that rather than
what we believe is the right thing to
optimize perfect last session last
statement that's a lot of pressure I'm
gonna copy something I read in a book a
few weeks ago the more you learn and the
more you experiment that increase the
chances of you making the right decision
that is true for both humans and machine
learning that's why I think it's very
very interesting concept to optimize
test learn and then go back and do it
again this is even almost the final word
for the entire 14th
and that's Tamsin's trouble cool perfect
do we do questions or not no okay
so if there are any more questions
please feel free to find the two of them
and me if you need at the drinks later
on otherwise we're gonna hand it back to
Tamsin and I thank you both for
competing on stage and being our guest
and sharing your best practices thank
you thank you
you